[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le débat nous
parlerons ce soir de la place du
numérique à l'école comme dans beaucoup
de secteurs les technologies numériques
transforme l'enseignement en salles de
classe les tablettes remplace les
traditionnels cahiers les tableaux
numériques interactifs se substitue aux
ardoises à crest quant au célèbre cahier
de correspondance
c'est maintenant une application que les
parents peuvent consulter à la maison
cette mutation en cours ne fait pourtant
pas l'unanimité progrès pour les uns le
numérique ne doit pas pour les autres
envahir l'univers de l'enfant avec nous
pour en débattre jean michel fourgous
mer les républicains d'elancourt et
bertrand mesure secrétaire départemental
du syndicat de professeurs
snuipp-75 je me tourne d'abord vers vous
jean michel fourgous votre ville est
pionnière en matière de numérique à
l'école vos collégiens apprennent sur
des tablettes vous êtes aussi équipées
de tableaux numériques et de robots et
vous êtes vous même l'auteur d'un
rapport positif sur le numérique remis
en 2010 à luc chatel le ministre de
l'éducation de l'époque quel bénéfice le
numérique apporte-t-il aux élèves eh
bien d'abord ça augmente leur créativité
ça les rend plus autonome donc ils
apprennent à apprendre tout seul et ça
augmente surtout et ça c'est très
important la confiance en soi
voilà donc rien que ces trois paramètres
et surtout en fait ça augmente le
plaisir d'apprendre un plutôt que de gaz
et un enfant c'est bien d'avoir des
données les connaissances à lui
transmettre il faut d'abord lui donner
envie il apprend donc ça c'est une forme
de garantie d'augmenter l'envi le
plaisir d'apprendre l'arabe à prendre il
changé ils échangent beaucoup plus vite
aujourd'hui le monde échange c'est un
démultiplicateur des changes une
rapidité d'accès à l'information bien
sûr c'est un plaisir d'avoir
l'information tout de suite donc ça
transforme complètement et en plus ça
développe un petit peu une sorte de
culture des sciences de l'ingénieur est
évident qu'ils ont un autre mode de
raisonnement pour régler un problème
c'est un bilan que vous avez pu faire
avec le recul que vous avez aujourd'hui
par rapport aux élèves d'elancourt oui
par rapport aux élèves dès lors en cours
mais d'autres communes aussi se sont
lancés c'est le cas bercy c'est le cas à
maurepas mais c'est le cas dans d'autres
villes de france a bien sûr il ya aussi
une autre chose que j'ai oublié de vous
dire qui est très importante c'est que
ça augmente le plaisir d'apprendre du
prof alors quand vous augmentez le
plaisir de reprendre année et le plaisir
d'apprendre d'un prof je peux vous dire
vous pouvez rentrer chez l'équation qui
vous semblent maintenant
bertrand mesure cette mutation en cours
or less certains dubitatifs je parlerai
de l'étude de l' ocde qui a conclu quand
même sur le fait que le numérique ne
réduirait pas l'échec scolaire vous avez
vous des réserves au sein de votre
syndicat oui alors il ya des réserves
qui sont d'abord liés au développement
de l'enfant en particulier chez les très
jeunes enfants pour que la maturation
neurologiques et que la construction des
fonctions cognitives supérieures se
fasse dans de bonnes conditions
il est nécessaire que les enfants soient
confrontés à leur environnement dans une
démarche motrices et cette démarche
motrices ne peut se faire
au travers des crans donc il est
absolument indispensable que jusqu'à
trois ans c'est d'ailleurs les
conclusions de serge tisseron qui a fait
une étude et qui en a tiré de bonnes
pratiques qui s'appelle 3 6 9 12 il est
indispensable que les très jeunes
enfants autant que possible puissent
avoir des activités motrices et tout ce
qui est écrans doivent éviter être
éviter autant que possible
d'autre part vous l'avez dit le cd2e met
en garde les pays contre une sur
pratiques de l'écran puisque dans cette
étude de l ocde ce qui était pointé
c'est que paradoxalement les élèves
français qui ont peu de pratique de
l'écran était bien meilleur lecteur sur
écran que d'autres pays où les enfants
par contre passé énormément de temps sur
leur tablette ou sur des écrans
d'ordinateurs
je rajouterais que par exemple la chine
connaît une explosion exponentielle de
la myopie et c'est certainement dû aussi
en partie c'est l'une des pistes qui est
explorée
que au fait que les et les enfants sont
confrontés trop tôt à des écrans et que
le développement de l'oeil ne peut pas
se faire dans de bonnes conditions voilà
ça ce sont des réserves très forte
maintenant
l'informatique au sens large les outils
modernes de communication sont un
incontournable dans les programmes
scolaires et dans ce cas un enfant doit
apprendre quand il va à l'école mais au
même titre pour nous c'est une
amélioration de ce que pouvait être à
une époque l'imprimante freinet c'est
une
une opportunité s'ouvrir sur le monde et
d'avoir une bibliothèque absolument
phénoménale qui s'enrichit de contenus
vidéo donc il permet d'avoir une
ouverture absolument extraordinaire vous
évoquez tout à l'heure les robots il
faut savoir que les robots à l'école
existe depuis 30 ans puisque quand j'ai
commencé ma carrière on a la possibilité
de programmer des petits sourires
dans les classes de maternelle
d'ailleurs où ont commencé à travailler
sous une forme de code qui d'ailleurs a
relativement peu évolué et qui
permettait j'évoquais tout à l'heure la
structuration des fonctions cognitives
supérieures kipré permettait aux jeunes
enfants d'essayer de penser leur
activité au travers de procédures
d'algorithmes etc mais c'était je dirais
c'est un plus ce ne doit pas être le
préalable à tout apprentissage et
dernier point si je peux me permettre
c'est que les études de l' ocde
d'ailleurs le pointent également et
toutes les études scientifiques l'ont
démontré le numérique peut être un
apport pour l'école dans la mesure où
deux impondérables sont quand même à
vérifier c'est les moyens financiers mis
à
disposition de l'école et deuxièmement
une formation de qualité qui permettent
de présenter des outils qui renvoie bien
ce que les enfants doivent apprendre à
l'école très bien alors d'ailleurs des
machines pour enseigner existe depuis
les années 60 si je ne me trompe donc le
cette notion de numérique et de machines
pour assiter l'enseignement mais on
n'est pas récente donc des problèmes
sanitaires vous les avez soulevé l'idée
c'est donc que le numérique apporte un
progrès jean-michel fourgous mais il
faut l'encadrer à partir de quel âge
vous vos élèves à elancourt sont ils mis
donc sont-ils doté de tablettes alors
moi d'abord eu donc je suis
j'ai vécu les écrans très tôt à l'école
je m'ennuyais je me suis rendu à l'école
je l' ai connu
je suis pas très bonne élève
mais j'étais plutôt fort maton j'ai raté
les huit des seize ans entre le mieux
sont tout le monde parce que il y avait
eu bm société ses brillantes à l'époque
et j'ai un copain qui enseignait
peu avec l'ingénieur et il m'a fait
rentrer chez eux et j'étais fasciné et
donc les écrans j'en ai abusé moi très
tôt ben on est au bout de trois ans j'ai
repris mes études j'ai passé des canons
du bac quand j'ai fait un doctorat de
psychologie
après sur le numérique l'arrivée du
numérique et l'impact que ça allait
faire dans la société des jeunes
étudiants s'étaient pas plaintes mais
j'étais toujours j'étais toujours devant
des écrans j'étais extrêmement est
exposé entre guillemets bon ensuite donc
je suis devenu ingénieur
junior crs de l'éducation nationale et
j'ai travaillé sur les premiers systèmes
bon inutile de vous dire que après
j'étais député ou sage et les missions
parlementaires où
j'allais voir
harvard hong kong à shanghai a encore
récemment il ya quinze jours j'étais en
italie et la bocconi à milan les écrans
où les enfants montrent bien aujourd'hui
enfin les adolescents et étudiants
quand on leur demande quelle est la part
du temps vous passer
on pourra prendre votre père d'apprendre
ça quel est l'impact coup passé soit ce
genre d'outils et sur des livres ou sur
ou en conférence ils listent 80 90 % là
dessus et 10% en amphi ou en cours ou
avec des livres ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que c'est bien et qu'ils
apprennent plus vite enfin c'est vrai
harvard c'est vrai a hong kong les
unités dans les universités que c'est
bon il est évident que la culture
informatique ou numérique est très forte
aujourd'hui dans les écoles qui ont les
meilleurs résultats donc faut être
conscient et en plus même temps c'est un
outil qui lutte contre les inégalités cc
c'est quand vous voyez voilà que les
enfants n'ont pas les mêmes livres n'ont
pas les mêmes dictionnaires ont pas le
même prof veut dire qu'elle est que ça
vous êtes en train de demain de 2,2 des
villes un de vos quotas à cheval
africains des pays qui ont manqué en
sont un peu en souffrance ou si c'est
négatif de 10 à les résoudre
grâce au numérique éducatif pour en
revenir à elancourt à partir de quel âge
vos élèves sont-ils et dans la mer
écoutez moi en étudiant bien sûr les
difficultés des enfants puisque j'avais
lancé le député contre l'échec scolaire
jettera aussi dans ma circonscription
bon ben vous rendez bien compte que
c'est avant la 6e que tout se passe
maintenant des 40% alors je sais pas si
ces déchets qui puisqu'elle est le terme
qui fut utilisée cliquez sur un cheval
mais 40% des enfants qui sortent du cm2
ne sont pas aux normes de l'ue
questionnable continuellement donc ça
veut dire quand il est délaissé la
hausse à partir de quelle classe voulu
maternelle
déjà démissionné mais bien sûr en
élémentaire chaque enfant à elancourt à
une tablette personnalisé pour lui pour
rentrer le soir chez lui et ça commence
en maternelle si dans toutes les classes
ont tous athées et nine tableau
numérique ils ont 27 robes on vous l'a
dit ils ont des cours d'anglais par
visioconférence avec des profs
d'angleterre merci jean michel forêt
bertrand mesure n est ce pas trop tôt
par rapport à ce que vous dise juste
avant il n'y a pas une notion j'ai
évoqué l'âge de 3 ans je pense que ça
c'est un incontournable parce que
jusqu'à trois ans un enfant c'est ce que
je disais a besoin pour son
développement
[Musique]
raw logique de dettes dans un rapport
direct à son environnement de manipuler
d'essayer d'aider comment dirais-je de
pratiquer sur le plan moteur et c'est ça
qui lui permet de structurer saint
samson esprits à partir de 3 ans rien
n'interdit ce qu'on utilise des écrans
mais l'écran ne doit pas se substituer à
l'essentiel alors je on peut saluer et
saluer particulièrement la la démarche
d'elancourt qui a toujours mis en avant
la nécessité d'équiper les écoles et
d'aller bien au delà puisque les élèves
sont les mêmes équipés à titre personnel
mais ce sont des moyens énormes et très
souvent ce qui manque au quotidien dans
les écoles maternelles puisque ont
évoqué les plus jeunes et parfois même
dans les écoles élémentaires
c'est parfois des salles de motricité
bien équipé ses des cours de récréation
permettant à l'enfant de faire des
expériences c'est la possibilité de
s'ouvrir sur son environnement
c'est à dire de pouvoir sortir à
l'extérieur et de compléter l'expérience
qu'il peut avoir à l'école dans le cadre
de la classe par une expérience d'aller
danser au bord de la mer d'aller en
montagne d'aller voir des animaux
d'aller à la campagne etc c'est
indispensable et c'est indispensable
parce que les enfants en ont besoin tout
simplement pour grandir alors notre le
numérique doit être complémentaire des
méthodes d'apprentissage que je crois
que tout ça rentre dans des éléments
complémentaires à une époque on
on pratique l apprentissage dans les
classes il y avait très peu de livres
quand le livre est arrivé il est venu
s'insérer tout naturellement dans dans
ces zones d'apprentissage il n'y a
aucune raison de se priver d'un outil
qui a une petite ouverture
extraordinaire sur l'extérieur et qui en
plus c'est ce que disait monsieur
fourgous offre des opportunités
de développement et une manipulation que
les outils qui existait jusqu'à présent
ne permettait pas de faire j'ajouterai
quand même qu'il faut il faut terminer
malheureusement je vais juste un mot de
conclusion pour chacun jean michel
fourgous quand même il y a des limites à
cela on a des témoignages de mamans qui
se plaignent du fait que leurs enfants
copie colle des informations sur
internet à partir de leur tablette ne
vérifie pas n'assimile finalement pas
que dites vous à cela et je vous
donnerai la parole oui mais des excès il
y en a toujours mais on ne peut pas
juger c'est une dépendance révolution
vous êtes une grande révolution et aussi
par exemple l'autisme on a ouvert une
classe on est de 62 60 communes dans les
yvelines celle en cours on a ouvert une
classe pour les parents qui ont des
enfants autistes bouge ta classe on a
une opération on change même
l'organisation du de s'asseoir la façon
un bon mais pas fait pour être ses six
heures particulièrement devant un voilà
devant une table donc on change on
change les robots ici ils savent qu des
mains les enfants et avec leur tablette
on est on sait que je rappelle qu'en
plus il serait fait on est 35 m sur 37
au niveau des inégalités bas ils
encourront on est en train de
s'améliorer considérablement et on va
voir a pris pour ça donc ça des apports
pas négligeable même si jean costes
c'est un grand débat jeu 90e avant
vraiment vraiment pour conclure juste un
mot je dirais justement ce qui concerne
les inégalités et l'étude de le céder
elle montre bien c'est que ce n'est pas
la surexposition à l'écran qui permet
d'appréhender les contenus mais bien une
démarche intellectuelle est avant tout
ce qu'il faut privilégier c'est cette
démarche intellectuelle pas la
surexposition à l'écran merci on
s'arrêtera là ce soir merci à tous les
deux pour ceux que le sujet intéresse
sachez qu'il y à un débat organisé sur
la question à la librairie le pavé du
canal demain soir merci à vous très
bonne soirée
[Musique]